I want to continue in volume 12 taking up at January the 25th, 1919 and it says
that the divine will is light and one who lives in it becomes light. This is
the transformation that has to happen inside of us that we actually become like
God and God is light and God is love. So Louisa says having spent most bitter
days of privation of my sweet Jesus, of my life, of my all, my poor heart could
take no more and I was saying to myself what a hard love is reserved for me. After
so many promises he has left me. Now this is the usual crisis that she goes into
in his absence. So she says where is his love now? Who knows whether I myself have
not been the cause of his abandonment, rendering myself unworthy of him or
maybe it was that night when he wanted to speak about the troubles of the world
and he started saying that the heart of man was still bloodthirsty and that the
battles are not finished because the thirst for blood is not yet extinguished
in the heart of man. So here Louisa is finding a reason why she could blame
herself for the fact that she's having this deprivation from the Lord and yet
she has had endless explanations from him that this is not the reason but she's
showing us what we're actually like and that we're much more likely to say that
we are at the cause of what is happening to us than the actual reason that the
Lord explains. So she goes around this round about quite frequently and so she
said to him Jesus you always want to talk about these troubles. Let's leave
them aside. Let's talk about something else and he afflicted remains silent.
Maybe he was offended she said but what she said forgive me I won't do it anymore.
So long as you come that's the whole issue as far as Louisa is concerned. So
when I was saying this at other announcements she's right to call it
nonsense I felt myself lose consciousness so she goes into ecstasy. The Lord is
there she just won't acknowledge that he wants to be there in the way that he
chooses not the way she chooses and I saw my sweet Jesus inside of me of course
that's Luke 17 21 the kingdom of God is within you and one Corinthians 3 16 no
you not that you are the temple of the living God and that the spirit of God
dwells in you which she saw Jesus alone and taciturn walking from one point of
my interior to another and as though he would stumble at one point and bump into
another I was all confused she said and did not dare to tell him anything but I
thought who knows how many sins there is that makes Jesus bump into but he all
goodness looked at me and though he seemed tired and was dripping with sweat
he told me it's very important my daughter he said poor martyr not of faith but of
love and not of human love but of divine love you are a divine martyr because
everything she does is done in the divine will therefore it's at the divine
level and she finds this difficult to grasp as any of us would and you're a
divine martyr because your most cruel martyrdom is my privation which places
on you the seal of a divine martyr why do you fear and doubt about my love and
besides how could I leave you I dwell in you as within my own humanity so I want
to give you one Corinthian 6 16 there and John 14 20 to 21 you in me and I in
you I dwell in you as within my humanity and just as I enclose the entire world
in my humanity so do I enclose it in you so Jesus encloses the entire world in
in Louisa and there she is complaining as if there's something wrong did you not
see that while I was walking I bumped and then I stumbled those were the sins the
evil soul and evil souls that I encountered what pain for my heart it is
from within you he said that I allot the destiny of the world now that needs to be
underlined and colored that if a person is truly living in the divine will then
that person's soul is the throne of God on earth and it is from there that he
reigns it is your humanity that shelters me of course she's a living host as
well isn't she just as mine did for my divinity if my divinity did not have my
humanity to give a shelter the poor creatures would have had no escape
either in time or in eternity we would have had to take the full
consequences of divine justice so for that I want to give you Revelation 6 16 to
17 and divine justice would no longer look at the creature as its own in other
words deserving preservation but as an enemy deserving destruction now since the
resurrection my humanity is glorious and so another humanity is needed that may
grieve and suffer and share my pains with me and that will love souls together
with me and lay down its life in order to save them so I want to give you
Colossians 1 24 and Galatians 6 17 so Jesus is saying now that
Louisa is living in the divine will and she is his throne on earth then and she's
a living host as well well he's looking for somebody else to live his life on
the earth so that person would have to grieve suffer and share the pains with
Jesus and so he said to her and this person would have to be ready to lay
down its life in order to save them he said this is necessary for me in other
words Christ must be on earth as well as in heaven and he said I have chosen you
with all her complaints and all the rest of it she is the chosen one aren't you
happy therefore he said because I've chosen you I want to tell you everything
my pains the chastisements that creatures deserve so that you may take part in
everything and from one single thing with me in other words from being
completely at one with me in the divine will and this is also why I want you in
the height of my will that means in the summer of this experience in other words
he wants her in the greatest possible position of union with him someone who
has gone into the deepest depths of the divine will that is actually possible
for a creature this is amazing stuff you would become one with me one single
thing and this is also why I want you in the height or in the summit of my will
so that wherever you cannot reach with your will as a creature with mine you
will reach everything and everything that befits the office of my humanity
in other words Jesus wants another Jesus on the earth therefore fear no more and
do not afflict me with your pains with your fears that I may abandon you I get
enough of these from others he says please don't add to it do you want to
increase my pain with yours no be sure your Jesus will not leave you when he
says be sure he's saying be certain and this is truth itself speaking that's John
14 6 I am the way the truth and the life and I also want to give you Joshua 1 5 I
will never leave you or desert you Jesus can't leave Louisa at this point
because the two of them are one and how can you separate one you can't afterwards
Jesus came back showing himself crucified and he transformed Louisa into
himself and also into his pains and he added my daughter my will is light so I
want to give you two Timothy 6 16 God lives in unapproachable light I want to
give you one John one five God is light okay my will is light he said and one who
lives out of the divine will actually becomes light so I want to give you Sam
104 verse 2 Lord you are robed in majesty you are dressed in a robe of light
Jesus was seen transformed into light on Mount Tabor as well so one who lives
out of the divine will becomes light that's what we have to be transformed
from this heavy weight of flesh into the light weight or the truly spiritual
condition of light and as light she easily enters into my most pure light
because light can mix with light and she has the key now this is the key of
divine will she has the key to open and to take whatever she wants but in order
to be able to open a key must be without rust or mud it has to be
operational and the key itself must be of iron otherwise the key can't open so
you're looking at something very strong and very reliable in the iron in the
same way the soul to be able to open with the key of my will must not mix the
rust of her own will with this there's the warning for us nor should must she
mix even a shadow of the mud of earthly things so we have to take on board that
anyone who wants to live in the divine will has to live a very high level of
spirituality very high we are the eagles of scripture and as eagles we
must fly at the very top of the mountains only in this way can we combine
together Jesus says light mixing with light but light won't mix with mud so
again I want to give you Hebrews 12 14 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the
presence of God okay and only in this way can we combine together and she the
soul can make whatever she wants of me there you have an absolutely
extraordinary humility and vulnerability of the divine love and I can do
whatever I want with her in other words this is total surrender of each to the
other in other words it's perfect marriage each completely given to the
other one of the very holy women who founded a religious order said that the
surrendered soul had found paradise on earth the surrendered soul is the eagle
flying very high so after this Louisa said I saw my human mother and
a late confessor of mine of course she's now talking about people who have gone
on in death to the other dimension so she said I wanted to tell them about my
state and they said to me now here is the Lord allowing souls on the other side
communicate with Louisa in these days you have run the risk that the Lord
would suspend you completely from the state of victim and we the whole of
purgatory and heaven now you know where the priest and the mother are okay both
of them are in purgatory allowed to speak to her we the whole of purgatory
and heaven have prayed very much and how much we did so that the Lord would not
suspend you in other words the members of the church suffering and the church
triumphant are much more aware than Louisa is of the enormity of the office
that's been given to her from this you can understand how justice is still full
of grave chastisements therefore have patience and do not get tired so January
the 27th 1919 the three mortal wounds of the heart of Jesus
Louisa said she was in her usual state and when Jesus came she could see his
adorable heart all full of wounds and which there were rivers of blood rushing
out and he said my daughter among the many wounds that my heart contains there
are three wounds which give me mortal pains and such bitterness of sorrow as
to surpass all the other wounds together these are the pains of my loving souls
there's the shock number one when I see a soul all mine suffering because of me
this is Louisa tortured trampled upon ready to suffer even the most painful
death for me I feel her pains as if they were my own
Louisa speaks as if Jesus doesn't really know what she's going through and she
wants to tell him what she's going through and she hasn't grasped that Jesus is
actually experiencing the same pain as her because he's one with her the two of
them are inseparable in the divine will I feel her pains as if they were my own
maybe even more love knows how to open deeper gaseous to the extent of making
one not feel the other pains that is outside of this in other words all the
other pains don't match to the depth of this pain first into this first wound he
said enters my dear mother as number one how her heart pierced because of my
pains overflowed into mine and felt vividly all its piercings and in seeing
her dying yet not dying because of my death I felt the torment the harshness
of her martyrdom in my heart and I felt the pains of my death which the heart
of my mother felt and my heart died together with hers so all my pains
united together before the pains of my mother surpassed everything it was right
that my celestial mother have the first place in my heart both in sorrow and in
love and that's perfectly obvious when you do the hours of the passion and
realize that blessed mother was with Jesus all the way even though she was
not physically present for most of it she only appeared at the beginning and at
the cross but she was there all the time so it was right that my celestial
mother would have the first place in my heart both in sorrow and in love because
each pain suffered for love of me opened seas of graces and of love which poured
into her pierced heart so mare in Latin is see Maria is Mary and the seas of grace
and love were poured into her in abundance into this wound also enter
all the souls who suffer because of me and out of pure love so this would
include Louisa and other victim souls who offer themselves to the Lord you
yourself enter into it Jesus said and even if all offended me and no one loved
me I would find in you the love which would compensate me for all because he's
being loved in a divine manner therefore when souls cast me away and forced me
to run away from them very quickly I come to take refuge in you as in my
hiding place now Sam 32 verse 7 says Lord you are a hiding place for me and he
is saying that we are a hiding place for him also if we are living in the divine
will on earth I come to take refuge in you as in my hiding place and finding my
own love not theirs and suffering only for me I say I do not regret having
created the heavens and the earth and having suffered so much a soul who loves
me and who suffers for me is all my contentment my happiness my reward and
for everything I have done so first of all I want to give you Sam 1 1 9 verse 1 1
4 I want to give you Genesis 6 verses 5 to 8 where we're told that the Lord
did regret having made man because there was nothing on the earth but sin and
wickedness so if infinite love and infinite grace and beauty and purity
and wisdom and everything else that is God it could only see the exact opposite
on the earth you would certainly understand that he would regret it so if
you ask the question what did God get out of creating and redeeming us it's a
very good question you know he has given absolutely everything that he is to us
he's poured out all his graces he is poured out all his beauty his love his
attributes everything what did he get out of it and he says that a soul who
loves me and who suffers for me is all my contentment my happiness and my reward
for everything I have done love can be repaid by love alone St. John of the
Cross tells us that and so it's by loving Jesus in the divine will and
therefore loving him infinitely because divinely that is how we can actually
reward him for what he has done and so if we make reparation in the divine will
on the divine level then we're making proper reparation for all that has gone
wrong and Jesus continues as though putting all the rest aside I delight in
her and I play with her now most people that I know do not have a concept of God
playing with anybody and yet if you go to Proverbs 8 31 you're told that God is
at play everywhere in the world delighting to be with the children of men
since it's a wonderful image of a very playful daddy wanting to be with the
children and enjoy them however Jesus said this wound of love in my heart
while it is the most painful such as to surpass everything it contains two
effects at the same time it gives me intense pain and highest joy now if you
go back over the last 11 volumes as Luisa enters more and more and more deeply
into the passion of Jesus experiencing the passion but experiencing it only out
of love she says that she has experienced intense pain but also intense joy I think
Luisa and the other saints would also claim that in spite of everything Jesus
would have experienced intense joy on the cross in the midst of his intense
torture and that joy was not a felt thing in his body but the reality in his soul
that no matter what he was experiencing the result was going to be that redemption
was going to be available for everybody in other words it was worth it he was
paying a very high price but it was worth it so he says to Luisa that this pain
that he experiences gives him intense pain and also the highest joy it gives
unspeakable bitterness and indescribable sweetness painful death and glorious
life what a wonderful way to describe Jesus's death and resurrection these
are the excesses of my love which are inconceivable to the human mind no matter
how much we think about it and pray about it and contemplate it we still
don't get it they are inconceivable to the human mind the created mind and in
fact how many contentment did my heart not find in the sorrows of my pierced
mother does that mean that the Lord rejoiced in her sorrow no he rejoiced in
the fact that she was participating with him in paying the mactimum price for the
redemption of the human race so Jesus said that the second mortal wound of his
heart is in gratitude now if you've read any of Luisa at all you will realize
that Jesus identifies the human race as the ungrateful ones if you're long
enough on the planet yourself you will realize that is a very apt way of
describing human beings everything is their right according to them and people
don't even say thank you or sorry anymore because if you're absolutely
convinced that you have the right to everything why should you thank anybody
and so humility goes out the door then so the second mortal wound of my heart
Jesus said is in gratitude within gratitude that the soul closes my heart
if you just think of ourselves and just take children in a family just to take
one example if they're completely ungrateful to their parents does that
stimulate the parents to sacrifice more and more for them no way it stops it if
you do work to help people and they show absolutely no gratitude whatsoever does
enable you to persevere no it doesn't it closes your heart and Jesus says that
our in gratitude for all that he's given to him closes his heart to us as well
it's our own fault that statement that we make about each other is true we say
that person is his own worst enemy each one of us is our own worst enemy and one
of the things that we in the divine will must do is make reparation for the
ingratitude of the human race to the Lord within gratitude the soul closes my
heart even more she herself turns the key with double locks oh dear Ephesians
520 and my heart swells because it wants to pour graces and love but it cannot
and it cannot because the soul has closed it and has put on it the seal of her
ingratitude and I become delirious I agonize without hope that this wound
may be healed because ingratitude keeps in bittering it more and more giving me
mortal pain so there is one of the major blocks to reaching union with God
ingratitude make sure you thank the Lord for absolutely everything the third
wound is the key to hell the third one is obstinacy
the scripture also calls that hardness of heart and if you go to the book of
Exodus the pharaoh of the Exodus is the perfect example of hardness of heart
no matter what God said or did he just wouldn't budge I also want to give you
Isaiah 48 verse 4 and Deuteronomy 230 the third wound is obstinacy what mortal
wound for my heart Jesus said obstinacy is the destruction of all the goods that
I have done for the soul it is the signature of declaration that the soul
places that she no longer recognizes me and that she no longer belongs to me oh
dear in other words this hardness of heart cuts us out of the kingdom of God
it is the key of hell into which the soul goes to hurl herself my heart feels
the tearing of it it is torn to pieces and I feel one of those pieces being
taken away from me what a mortal wound obstinacy is now if you go to the hours
of the passion and the description of the scourging of Jesus
Louisa explains that the pieces of his flesh that actually fell to the ground
represented the souls that were lost that's a frightening thing so Jesus feels
himself being torn to pieces as parts of his own body are actually torn from him
what a mortal wound obstinacy is my daughter he said enter into my heart and
take part in these wounds of mine sympathize with my tormented heart let us
suffer together and let us pray so Louisa said that she entered into his heart
and how painful but beautiful it was to suffer and pray with Jesus we now come
to January the 29th 1919 and we get an absolutely extraordinary message from
Jesus explaining how God renews humanity every 2,000 years and so you were given
here the history of the divine will I was doing the adoration to the wounds of
blessed Jesus and at the end she said I recited the creed intending to enter
into the immensity of the divine will in which are all the acts of creatures
past present and future and even those acts that the creature should do and
because of negligence or wickedness they don't do now I want you to notice the
intention it is extremely important that we tell the Lord what our intention is
and it's also equally important to tell him our motivation in other words I'm
doing this for love of you alone and not doing it for any other reason and most
particularly I'm not doing it to try and grow and sanctity myself in the divine
will you leave that aside you're only interested in the glory of God and the
salvation of souls you've gone beyond looking to your own sanctity if you're
interested in your own sanctity go back to an earlier spirituality but you're
not in divine will so Louisa recited the creed with the intention that she could
reach all the acts that human beings did and should have done and could have done
if they wanted and she said my Jesus my love I enter into your
volition that means we fuse and with this creed I intend to redo repair all the
acts of faith which souls have not done all the disbelief and the adoration which
is due to God our Creator so she wants to make reparation for all the
unbelief and she wants to repair and redo acts that should have been done in
reciting the creed in other words some people just say the creed because that's
what you say but it doesn't actually mean anything for example people stand up
in church and they say I believe in God he is my father he is almighty he's the
creator of heaven and earth and they go home and they worry themselves to death
and they don't seem to realize that the statement they made in church and the
action they do at home are complete contradictions because if God really is
my father and he really is almighty and he really is the omnipotent creator of
heaven and earth what have I to worry about nothing it's like a child whose
father is a multi-millionaire where they worry about money of course not it's
just that spiritually we can be very contradictory so while she was saying
these and other things Louisa said she felt her intelligence being dissolved in
the divine will and I think this is beyond brilliant
it doesn't really matter whether you have university degrees or not when you're
in the divine will the Lord will infuse knowledge into you as he did to Louisa
and other saints I felt my intelligence being dissolved in the divine will she
said and a light investing my intellect now that light is the divine will one John
one five and two Timothy six sixteen a light investing my intellect inside of
which I could see my sweet Jesus now I want to give you John a twelve for that
because he said he was the light of the world and this light spoke and spoke we
would say communicated but who can say everything I will say it confusedly she
said and besides I feel such repentance that if obedience was not so strict
but more indulgent it would not force me to make such sacrifices but you my life
give me strength and do not leave the poor little ignorant one on her own I've
said that slowly because no matter what gifts God gives to us no matter what
grace he pours into it we remain nothing and we have to remain in our
nothingness and we have to remain consciously in our nothingness it's the
only safe place to be and so Louisa never let's go of the reality she knows
of herself that of herself she's a poor thing she's a little thing and she's an
ignorant thing she hasn't any education at all but we're all poor little and
ignorant on all levels but unfortunately if we have a bit of education we think
otherwise and then she makes an effort to say what Jesus was communicating to her
in this divine light in this infused knowledge so he said my beloved daughter
I want to make known to you the order of my providence it is extremely important
for all of us who are trying to live in the divine will to live within God's
order to live within his order in every way every course of 2000 years he said
I have renewed the world in the first 2000 years I renewed it by the flood
you'll get that in Genesis 6 to 10 chapters 6 to 10 in the second 2000 I
renewed it with my coming on the earth that's the four gospels in which I
manifested my humanity from which as though from many fishers my divinity
Sean fourth now the gospels tell us some of the moments when Jesus divinity
really Sean fourth like the night he walked on water and said ego Amy it is
I and the day he was transformed on Mount Tabor when they the privileged
three saw him transformed into light these were fishers or openings through
which his divinity showed forth and the good good people and the very saints of
the past two thousand years have lived from the fruits of my humanity in other
words the church has fed on the fruits of the incarnation for the past two thousand
years and in drops they've enjoyed my divinity because they had not been
given the revelation of how to live at the divine level now we are at the turn
of the third two thousand years and there will be a third renewal this is the
reason for the general confusion everywhere it's nothing other than the
preparation for the third renewal and even the second renewal I manifested what
my humanity did and suffered and very little of what the divinity was doing
now in the third renewal after the earth has been purged and the current
generation destroyed now he's talking about it's 1919 so he's talking about the
interim between the first and the second world wars I think that if you go to the
book of Revelation and you are shown very clearly between chapter 6 and 10 and
then in chapter 16 three massive waves of purification I think that's the first
world war the second world war and the third world war which is still to break
out upon us so after the earth has been purged and the current generation
destroyed for the most part I will be even more generous with creatures and I
will accomplish the renewal by manifesting what my divinity did within my
humanity so that's what he's doing with Louisa during one of those waves of
chastisement the second one the second world war
sorry this is in between the first and the second world war so what he's doing
here is he's revealing this way ahead of time so that when the church needed
this food it would find it there if you go back to the journey of the people of
Israel through the desert at the time of Moses they didn't find the manner until
they needed it they didn't find the quails until they needed them and they
didn't find the living water from the rock until they needed it nor did Moses
raise up the bronze serpent for them until they needed it the Lord has the
solution for us before we know we have the problem that's why we should trust
him beyond reason
now he said in this third renewal after the earth has been purged and the current
generation destroyed for the most part I will be even more generous with creatures
and I will accomplish the renewal by manifesting what my divinity did within
my humanity how my divine will acted with my human will how everything remained
linked with me how I did and redid everything that's the divine version
that he made of everyone and even every thought of each creature was redone by
me and it was sealed with my divine volition my love wants its outpouring
and wants to make known the excesses of my divinity which my divinity
operated in my humanity for the good of souls which surpassed by far the excesses
that my humanity operated externally so in the revelation about the divine will
Jesus is showing us all that was locked up inside of his humanity if I can use
those words and what was not manifested at the time that he was on the earth in
the incarnation but is being manifested fully now that the church 2000 years
later is more mature and has suffered and grown somewhat this is often why this
is also why I often speak to you about the living in my will which I've not
manifested to anybody until now that's as clear as daylight so none of the
saints beforehand could have lived out of the divine will when it wasn't even
revealed to them they lived out of the humanity of Jesus through him with him
and in him as the church tells us at the most they have known the shadow of my
will the grace the sweetness that doing it contains but to operate inside of it
by fusing oneself with the divine will to embrace immensity to multiply
oneself with me and penetrate everywhere even while being on the earth
both in heaven into heaven and into the hearts of all to lay down the human
ways and act with divine ways that was not known that is the immense privilege
that's given to you and me so much so that not to a few it will appear strange
and those who do not keep their minds open to the light of truth will not
understand a thing and I'm sure all of us have the similar experience of trying
to talk about the divine will to people that you would imagine would be more
than ready and more than delighted to receive it to find the door closed but
those who do not keep their minds their minds open you see we can decide that a
certain thing is it and we're not receiving anything else and so we close
our minds to it and you know that if a human being closes their minds to you
you get no quarter and if they closed their minds to evidence you get no
quarter this is witnessed every day in the courts where a person who is accused
can close their mind completely to all the evidence that's presented to them
and still say they're innocent when it can be proven publicly that they're
guilty it's because they've closed their minds to the truth whereas if they had
opened their minds to the truth they would have opened their minds to
repentance and recovery instead of a long jail sentence
those who do not keep their minds open to the light of truth will not understand
anything but I little by little will make my way manifesting first one truth
and then another about this living in my will so that they will end up they
meaning the human race they meaning the church will in the end
understand it look at the patience of the Lord it's divine patience humans
don't have patience do they so Jesus continues now he said the first link
which connected the true living in my will was my humanity so we this is we
start at this point in revealing the divine will my humanity identified with
my divinity and swam in the eternal volition and kept tracing all the acts
of creatures in order to make them its own and to give to the father a divine
glory on the part of creatures let's stop there for one second Jesus has given
the father divine glory for me he's given him divine reparation for me he has
given him divine gratitude for me and so on now it is time for me to join him in
the divine will and put my fear beside his so that I tank the father with a
divine thanksgiving and I glorify him with a divine glory that I love him with
a divine love and then what Jesus did for me has been worth it
Jesus said I gave to the father a divine glory on the part of creatures and I
brought to all the acts of creatures the value the love and the kiss of the
divine volition in this fear of the eternal volition I could see all the
acts of souls that could possibly be done and were not done and the very good
acts that were done badly and I did those he said which were not done and
redid those who are done badly now these acts not done and done only by me are
all suspended in my will and I await others to come to live in my volition
and repeat in my will that which I did this is why he said I chose you Louisa
as the second link in connection with my humanity forming one single link with
mine living in my volition repeating my own acts and we've been watching Louisa
do that for many volumes otherwise on this side my love would remain without
outpouring this side is the earth heaven is the other side so on the earth side
my love would remain without outpouring without glory on the part of creatures
for what my divinity operated in my humanity and without the perfect purpose
of creation which must be enclosed and perfected in my will now notice the
purpose of creation must be enclosed and perfected in my will so I want to give
you Romans 8 19 there that even the whole of creation is crying out for the sons
of God who will do this so that all of creation can recover as well from the
disaster of the fall of the human race
it would be as if I had shed all my blood suffered so much and no one had
known it who would have loved me what heart would be shaken no one and therefore
in no one would I have had my fruits and the glory of redemption as Galatians 5
20 for the fruits of the spirit that are produced in us
so Louisa interrupted Jesus and said my love if there's so much good about this
living in the divine will why did you manifest it before now she cannot see
and it's difficult for us to see that the divine order is perfect like God
himself and it's infinite and its its beauty is beyond imagining and if you
have a very beautiful picture that's been painted by a great artist and there's
a tiny little bit of it not right it just spoils the whole thing
everyone knows that the painter looks at his painting his or her painting and goes
back and touches it up and says no I think we need something slightly
differently there and we often encounter Jesus working in Louisa's soul and she
says to him what are you doing he says I'm touching it up
there's the divine artist and so I want to give you Ephesians 210 that we are
God's work of art okay created in Christ Jesus so Louisa wants to know why
did you do it before he said my daughter there is a divine order in things first
he said I had to make known what my humanity did and suffered on the outside
that's add extra in order to be able to dispose souls to knowing what my
divinity did on the inside add intra so we'd never get to the interior if we
had not looked at the exterior and that's why the church gave us the stations of
the cross and gave us the mysteries of the rosary to enable us to continuously
meditate on the life passion death and resurrection of Jesus so that we would
always keep it in mind and therefore we would always keep the connection with
Jesus alive first he said I had to make known what my humanity did and suffered
on the outside so that's in the days of his incarnation in order to be able to
dispose souls to knowing what my divinity did on the inside add intra the
creature is incapable of understanding my work all together as we know from
studying these writings I have been continuously teaching the writings of
Louisa since 2011 and I am more and more convinced that I know nothing about them
every time I go back there's something new something I haven't seen before
something I haven't registered before and that's why I insist on everyone
associated with me studying these writings all the time the creature is
incapable of understanding my work altogether therefore I keep manifesting
myself little by little and that's what he does in our study of the writings as
well we only get it bit by bit sip by sip then from your link that's Louisa
from your link of connection with me the other links will be connected that
means Louisa is linked to Jesus in this operation of the divine will and we're
linked to Louisa to Jesus but we're all linked together so the image I would
give you is of a group of people climbing a mountain and they're all tied
on to each other and the the leader is the one who goes ahead and tells the
people closest to him you can put you can step there it's safe enough and then
they can tell the people behind them they can step up to the place where they
were and so on all down the mountain and they all edge up the mountain
together safely
Jesus said from your link Louisa of connection with me the other links of
souls will be connected as well that's us and I will have crowds of souls who
living in the divine will will redo all the acts of creatures and I will have
the glory of many suspended acts done only by me also from creatures and these
from all classes virgins which will mean nuns priests lay people according to
their office they will no longer operate humanly what penetrating into my will
their acts will multiply for all in a fully divine manner and I will have on
the part of the creatures the divine glory of many sacraments received and
administered in the human way of others that are profaned and others that are
solid with interest and of many good works in which I remain more dishonored
than honored I so much long for this time there's your Romans 8 19 again not
only is creation longing for these souls but the Lord said he was longing for
them as well his true children and you he said to Louisa pray and long for it
together with me and do not move your link of connection from me as the first
one so Jesus is the great link and then Louisa linked to him and we all linked
to him through Louisa so February the fourth 19 19 the interior passion so
Louisa says continue in my usual state for about three days I felt myself lost
in God so she's in constant ecstasy for three days many times good Jesus drew me
inside of his most sacred humanity and I swam in the immense sea of his divinity
so that's in the light oh how many things could be seen how clearly one could see
everything that the divinity operated in the humanity of Jesus and very often
Jesus interrupted my surprises telling her something so the thing that he
reveals to her now is that Jesus suffered the passion from the moment of
conception this is completely new see my daughter with what excess of love I
have loved the creature now that's Jeremiah 31 3 I have loved you with an
everlasting love and my love is constant my divinity was jealous of
entrusting to the creature the task of redemption making me suffer the passion
the creature was impotent to make me die as many times for as many creatures as
it come out and where to come out to the light of creation and not only to die
for every creature but also to die for as many mortal sins as they would have
the disgrace to commit the divinity wanted a life for each life of the
creature and wanted a life for each death which by mortal sin the creature gave
herself that's some tall order who could be so powerful over me as to give me so
many deaths if not my divinity who could have had the strength the love the
constancy to see me die so many times if not my divinity the creature would have
grown tired and fall in short and do not think that this crafting of my
divinity started late in other words in the last couple of days of his life but
as soon as my conception was accomplished even in the womb of my mother who many
times was aware of my pains and remained martyred and she felt death
together with me the chorid Emptrix so even from the maternal womb my divinity
took on the commitment of a loving executioner but because loving it was
even more demanding and inflexible so much so that my groaning humanity was
spared not even one thorn not one nail but not like the thorns and the nails and
discourages I suffered in the passion which creatures gave me and which did
not multiply as many as they inflicted that's how many there were rather those
of my divinity multiplied at each offense as many thorns for as many evil
thoughts now first of all I want to give you Sam 1 4 5 17 God only ever acts out
of love and if he demanded that Jesus even in his infancy even in his his
pre-born state would suffer this for us then you're talking about a love that's
completely incomprehensible to us and if Jesus would agree it's also
incomprehensible love to us so I want to give you Sam 51 verses 5 and 6 as well
so Jesus said he had as many thorns deaths for as many thorns and so on for
the many unworthy works he said I had as many blows for as many pleasures as
many pains for as much diversity of offenses therefore he said there were
seas of pains innumerable thorns nails and blows it's inconceivable to us
in the face of the passion which the divinity gave to me and Louisa brings
this out in the hours of the passion and the agony of Jesus in the garden the
different levels of passion the the passion of love the passion of sin and
then the passion that was given to him by the people in the face of the passion
which the divinity gave me the passion which creatures gave me on the last of
my days was nothing but a shadow it was only the image of what my divinity made
me suffer during the whole course of my life this is why I love souls so much
because they cost me so much they are those pains that are inconceivable to
the created mind which I agree therefore enter into my divinity and see and touch
with your own hand what I suffered so I want to give you Hebrews 10 28 there and
in the next paragraph we're going to be talking about the throne of justice that
was there for each creature so why would Jesus suffer and before I even read I
want to give you two Corinthians 5 verses 14 and 15 I want to give you one
Corinthians 15 3 and Romans 5 8 I don't know Louisa said I found myself inside
the divine immensity as it erected the throne of justice for each creature to
which my sweet Jesus had to answer for each act of the creature I honestly think
that nobody could explain this to you you really need to take it before the
throne of God and ask for enlightenment because when we grasp but we're going
to change drastically
Jesus had to suffer for each act of the creature suffer their pains their death
and pay the penalty for everything that was the thing that St Paul said he died
for me he gave his life for me he suffered those scourges for me he was
crowned for me he was nailed for me he gave his forgiveness on the cross for me
he showed me how to surrender to God from the cross I could go on and on but
I'm just giving you a hint as to how to deal with it Jesus was like a sweet
little lamb killed by divine hands to rise again and suffer even more deaths
oh God she said what harrowing pains to die in order to rise again and to rise
again in order to submit to a more harrowing death I felt myself dying and
seeing my sweet Jesus being killed so many times I would have wanted to spare
the one who loves me so much even just one death oh how well I understood that
only the divinity could make my sweet Jesus suffered so much and could boast
of having loved men to folly and to excess
therefore we've absolutely no excuse before the divine judgment none what so
ever because everything was has been paid for us and I've often imagined Jesus
saying to a soul that is condemning itself to hell did I not pay enough for
you did I not suffer enough did I not love you enough when his pains and his
suffering and his love are all infinite and beyond imagination so
Louisa said how well I understood that only the divinity could make my Jesus
suffer so much and could boast of having loved men to folly and to excess so I
want to give you John 15 9 and Jeremiah 31 3 I've loved you with an ever-lasting
love and I'm constant in my affection for you
neither angel nor man had this power in hand of being able to love us with such
great heroism and sacrifice as only our incarnate God had but who can say
everything my poor mind swam in the immense sea of light of love and of pain
and I remained as though drowned without being able to get out and if my beloved
Jesus had not drawn me into the little sea of his most holy humanity in which
my mind was not so emerged without being able to see the boundary I
couldn't have said a thing so first of all Louisa is absolutely swimming in the
immensity of the divinity and then she's drawn into the much smaller space of
Jesus's humanity which of course by comparison with the divinity is small
can you imagine how small we are if he's small in comparison with the divinity
and she said if this happened to happen she couldn't have said anything at all
so Jesus said beloved daughter birth from my life come into my will come and see
how much there is to substitute for so many acts of my instills suspended not
yet substituted for by creatures I want to give you John 1 verses 3 to 4 and
Colossians 1 24 so in this paragraph the Lord is going to tell us that our
mission is great and it's also fully divine my will he said must be in you as
the first wheel of the clock now he's thinking of well we would call a Swiss
watch see you've got the main wheel you've got the smaller wheels if the divine
will moves all the other wheels move and the clock signals the hours and the
minutes so all the accord is in the motion of the first wheel because God is
always the prime mover and if this first wheel has no motion the clock is
stopped it's a strange thing that if you actually go to the book of Exodus at
the very end of it and I think it's chapter 40 or 45 I can't remember it's
the very end of the book of Exodus you're told that when the people were
going through the desert they couldn't make the journey at all unless the cloud
which was guiding them rose from the camp and moved forward and wherever the
cloud moved to they moved and if the cloud didn't move they stopped they
stayed and so only if God moves first can we move otherwise we can do nothing
John 15 5 without me you can do nothing so all the accord is in the motion of
the first wheel and if this first wheel is no motion the clock is stopped in the
same way the first wheel in you must be my will and must give motion to all your
thoughts at 2 Corinthians 10 5 all our thoughts must be captivated and given to
Christ the first wheel in you must be my will which must give motion to your
thoughts your heart your desires and to everything and since my will is the
central wheel of my being of creation and of everything your motion coming out
from this center will come to substitute for the many acts of souls and
multiplying in the motions of all as the central motion it will come to lay
before my throne on their behalf the acts of creatures substituting for
everything therefore be attentive your mission is great and it's fully divine
we can do everything in him we can do nothing outside of him so that's
Philippians 4 13 I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength and John
15 5 without me you can do nothing we leave it there